have you ever been watching a video on
Android TV but you still wanted to
browse around to look for something new
then you need to use the new picture in
picture mode available in Android n hi
everyone I'm Wayne Piekarski from Google
and today I'm going to talk about
picture and picture on Android TV and
how to quickly support it in your apps
picture-in-picture
also known as pip is a new feature
available in Android and on Android TV
devices pip builds on the new Android
and multi window ap is to bring you an
intuitive multi window experience
specifically designed for Android TV
with picture and picture enabled in your
app users can continue watching your
content while they browse more content
in app and across apps on Android TV the
user selects the pip icon to put the
video in the top right corner pepp also
helps your users return to your app so
while they browse around for different
content it's now quick and easy for them
to return to your app even if they're a
completely different app without pip
once the user leaves your app they're
gone if you press and hold the home
button it will bring up the recent list
which allows you to make the pip full
screen or to stop it in order to support
pip in your app there are a few simple
changes that you'll need to make the
first to do is you need to add these few
lines to your payback activity in your
manifest file this tells Android that
your activity is specifically designed
to go in a pip mode and can be resized
by the system when pip is enabled we
suggest you only add these tags to video
playback activities as they provide the
best user experience for pip mode and
this is what users will come to expect
from the feature next add a button to
your UI so that your users can activate
pip if you're using the Leanback support
library we've already added a new
picture and picture action class that
allows you to easily drop a pip button
into your existing playback controls row
when the button is clicked simply run
activity enter picture in picture mode
and Android will handle the rest at any
time you can call the activity is in
picture in picture mode method to detect
whether your activity is in pip mode for
example when you switch to pip mode your
activity is considered to be paused so
you should continue video playback and
pause everything else
if you find that your video pauses when
you activate pip that's likely because
you're handling the play and pause logic
in on resume and on pause in Android and
we recommend your play pause logic
happenin on start on stop instead so be
sure to move that logic over to those
methods if you encounter that issue
finally you may notice that your
playback controls row still shows up in
the PIP window
this may confuse your users so we'll
need to hide those when we enter pip
mode and show them again once we exit
pip mode if you implement the media
session properly then play and pause
controls on the remote control or the
recent list will still work on the PIP
simply override the on picture in
picture mode changed in your activity or
fragment and Hydra controls if you're in
pip mode and that's it you're done your
app now supports pip and is ready to use
here's a few extra tips that will help
make sure your picture and picture
experience is polished for your users
first use the Android launch mode equal
single task on your pip enabled activity
to make sure your pip window
automatically closes when a user starts
playing a new video from within your
application we suggest you use the
picture in picture window only for
displaying your video content as this
provides the best user experience and
finally when you reach the end of your
video you should either autoplay our
next video or close the PIP
but don't go back to the fullscreen user
interface so go and check out our lean
back sample which shows you a full
implementation of how to incorporate
picture and picture in your app picture
and picture mode provides your users
with a great experience for viewing and
browsing content at the same time on
Android TV as you saw enabling pip in
your apps is easy and can help your
users stay engaged with your content
beyond the confines of your app so
that's it for today try out the PIP
support in the sample and join us in our
G+ community to discuss this and other
Android TV api's I'm a Piekarski and
I'll see you next time
you